okay but on certain issues we cannot be
totally open-minded because on some
issues you see a conflict of Rights and
conflict of claimed rights in a conflict
of Freedom so if we were debating tax
policy we might come to some
conciliatory middle ground and we might
hear all sides if we were discussing
immigration we might say okay we take in
three million immigrants a year today
conservatives don't want to take in any
more immigrants we've taken in a lot but
uh okay let's meet in the middle
somewhere on this issue we can't do that
because either the women have the
bathrooms or they don't either the women
have the sports teams or they don't
certain issues you can't just meet in
the middle on certain issues you would
split the baby which is no good for
anybody so here Brad is claiming the
freedom of the transgender identifying
people men who think that they're women
mistakenly to enter into the women's
bathroom and what I'm defending is the
genuine freedom and right of women to
have their own bathrooms only one of
those is going to win out only one of
those is in accordance with reality so I
I would just as soon defend the one that
happens to align with the truth